how are you why hey bucket how are you
he's not so good now after all it's my
bed to bathroom now ow ow ow
hey be careful you'll kill yourself and
focus all right no problem my little
life in the next
[Laughter]
I can swim like a dolphin in an ocean of
butterflies get really tired of this I'm
not my [ __ ] a pothead get it huh it's
good no I'm not no I'm not there we go
actually but it's in the pool it's gonna
go soggy damn my genius God you never
get a fine peds now he gave you the
ultimate strength descent
oh really yeah well then the white was
good all the chairs mr. white I'm a
professional I'm the best at what I do
a peds letter I Gandalf left now dude
some of these hiding spots are so full
for in here I got hangin what's this I
was like that's boring
yeah be in the hole never find me
Jesus it's just like when you say like a
vomiting Optimus Prime exactly I was
going
he's them helix Oh God
see look at that look at that Oh Lord
you cheater it's cheating you know you
know look like you're going so fast
you're skipping over the surface have a
seat you don't Dateline right to know
how you know you approach this girl
homie night gentlemen
I don't mean to stop your day line
conversation but there is something over
here that requires our attention
oh the methamphetamine chairs
take a seat take a seat port this chair
to the police thank you anything way to
make it easy for we're all stuck that's
awesome so not able to move not hard to
find if you want to live
so spooky what is going on my spirit
lives on people believe it no no no you
know okay I'm gonna cut your deal here
hi have you shovel recipes up I have you
shot no what I was gonna help you I had
to bury some bodies and now you'll never
find cry ever
[Laughter]
ah
I'm beautify they don't know where I
head oh right try come out of the
bathroom no young lady no this is your
father speaking and you respect me in my
house tell me tell me where they are
okay you know what okay okay
there's blood blood well that's a sign
death is on his way
[Laughter]
ken don't I don't want to get excited
but I think I'm on to something
I think this place is haunted
oh don't kill the culture
oh sorry big sorry sorry sorry
Yeah right I did it
stop me that way are you da Frieda I'm a
big fan man there's a time you blow up
all those planets man I'm like whoa whoa
okay
oops you're not gonna find him you're
not gonna find him where you are do it
again you're not gonna fight you know
[Laughter]
gay guys humping in the other room
you're back I mean nothing to help you
find a bottle of bleach why is it bad
you don't know how to properly prop I
didn't see all deception
well where did you get from there today
let's find the mirin [ __ ] I mean okay do
the Tony Hawk Oh ball bounce
ah let me listening to this
oh I'll stand on the box you get a
better angle on it yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
are you two straight don't judge me
can you guys stop making those noises
and find me please oh nice mix what are
you doing that's gay Ken oh geez why
she's got proof against this killer okay
this is not a matter what no it's a
doorway I thought I was impressed
hope you enjoyed this episode live like
if you didn't helps me out a lot I
really appreciate all the support let me
know if you want more prop hunt and I'll
see you in the next 1000 buzz
Adam you should go into that labor I'm
sure it will go fine come on you know I
don't know if you like it